et le secrétaire général de l'otan et
jens stoltenberg dit craindre que moscou
n'organise une attaque à l'aide d'armes
chimiques sous fausse bannière at il dit
c'est à dire faussement imputée aux
ukrainiens l'otan en force ces défenses
hurle son flanc oriental avec des
systèmes antimissiles patriot en pologne
en slovaquie c'est une déclaration de
secrétaire général la veille d'un sommet
extraordinaire qui aura lieu à bruxelles
demain on écoute
elle affirme protéger les civils mais et
les tuent des civils
et aujourd'hui elle lance des
accusations absurdes
selon laquelle il y aurait des
laboratoires biologique et des armes
chimiques en ukraine ce n'est qu'un
mensonge de plus
et nous nous inquiétons d'une éventuelle
opération sous fausse bannière
organisé par la russie et impliquant
éventuellement des armes chimiques